my name is Tom Byers I'm a professor of
management science and engineering here
at Stanford University I was a student
at Berkeley in my 20s and I got a
bachelor's and engineering an MBA and
then a PhD in management science in
operations research then in my 30s I
worked in Silicon Valley as an
entrepreneur and an executive and I was
very lucky to be involved with Symantec
Corporation during its formation but I
feel super lucky to have been a
professor here at Stanford for the last
20 years where I get involved in as many
things I can regarding innovation and
entrepreneurship education
I've always had a passion for learning
and frankly that means teaching ever
since I was a kid I've been trying to
teach something this included my
twenties when I taught guitar for a
living as well as in my 30s when I was
at symantec and I was helping a lot of
our employees develop professionally so
about 20 years ago I said maybe I should
do this full time and I was lucky enough
to land at Stanford and notice there was
a big problem why was it necessary for
students who wanted to learn about
entrepreneurship and innovation have to
go to business school that's terrific if
they wanted to but what about all the
students who want a major in engineering
won a major in the sciences or even the
humanities what about them so that is
what I've been working on the last 20
years and very excited to see how much
of a reach now we have with that that's
what makes me happy and what makes me
passionate
I like everybody
fault and entrepreneurship and
innovation have failed a number of times
the important thing is what you learn
from it so for example after symantec I
helped start a company called slate al
it was an amazing experience because my
co-founder was the person who invented
spreadsheets he had created visicalc and
his previous experiences so he and I
created a company called slate and it
was 20 some odd years ago when the idea
of interfacing with a computer I went
from just keyboards two pins and fingers
so of course we take that for granted
now but it was really fun to be on the
forefront well unfortunately we didn't
make it but because the hardware was not
mature enough and we frankly spent too
much money too fast we just didn't make
it so we learned it a significant number
of lessons from it including humility
I've had
the pleasure living here for 40 years
since high school in Atlanta Georgia and
I absolutely enjoy every second today
there's inspiration around every corner
it is 24 by seven in terms of people
willing to share their dreams I mean
they're ordinary people not everybody is
the founder of this or you know the
Nobel Prize winner of that but the it's
just fantastic could be in a community
of people who really really care about
where the world is headed and then how
to get there and they look at it with an
entrepreneurial mindset